bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du magazine culturel kiosque
alors ce soir nous allons nous
intéresser évidemment aux 31e journée
européenne du patrimoine avec notre
invité leur Valette du musée de la ville
on va parler aujourd'hui évidemment de
ce qui se passe autour de
l'agglomération il sera également
question du festival code rock à Manille
les hameaux qui a lieu les 10 et 11
octobre c'est de la musique et puis en
cinéma les avis de spectateurs et de
coups de cœur d'un professionnel du 7ème
art Bertrand Pignier des yeux d'Elsa à
Saint-Cyr l'école mais donc d'abord un
week-end sur le thème patrimoine
culturel patrimoine naturel ce sont les
journées du patrimoine
et on va parler avec vous leur Valette
bonsoir des choses à voir à entendre
à 50 ans en Yvelines un programme
extrêmement varié sur l'agglomération il
y a le thème de l'eau qui est récurrent
puisque c'est le thème nature cette
année pour les Journées du patrimoine
mais peut-être avant de parler de ce qui
se passe autour du thème de l'eau je
voudrais qu'on parle notamment d'une
visite assez exceptionnelle un château
qui est très peu ouvert au public vous
seriez de la verrière il est très
rarement vers au public parce que c'est
très compliqué pour eux de se rendre
disponible le Week-End c'est un château
qui est privé c'est le site de la MGEN
et donc vraiment ils font un geste
magnifique en ouvrant ce château c'est
un château qui du coup peu connu du
public mais qui vraiment a une emprise
sur le territoire de la verrière qui est
importante et qui vraiment recèle de
jolies choses à découvrir même s'il a
été très transformé il y a des pièces
entièrement avec des boiseries d'époque
il y a une chapelle qui mélange des
fraises Art Déco et des mosaïques un peu
à la byzantine donc il y a des jolies
surprises à découvrir sur ce château
donc on peut rentrer à l'intérieur
évidemment
à l'intérieur oui très
exceptionnellement on va rentrer à
l'intérieur et découvrir tout ça tout à
fait c'est un château je rappelle qu'il
a été fondé au 16e siècle et qui
aujourd'hui la propriété de la MGEN et
le parc en plus c'est ouvert au public
depuis quelques mois je crois
effectivement les habitants de la
verrière et tout le parc et on ne voit
pas bien le château
c'est l'occasion jamais et il reste des
places ça prend bien parce que il y a
des animations autour du patrimoine qui
sont en complet en vend parler mais là
il reste des places pour ce château de
La Verrière ce très beau château donc à
découvrir alors je l'ai dit la nature
c'est évidemment le thème de ces
journées du patrimoine on va parler de
l'eau et quand on parle de l'eau à 50
ans en Yvelines on pense étant la base
de loisirs forcément il y a beaucoup
d'animations qui vont avoir lieu autour
de cet étang il y a tout un programme
construit le samedi après-midi le 20
autour de la de l'île de loisirs
maintenant comme elle s'appelle
qui a proposé à la fois des visites
alors des visites autour du patrimoine
naturel phone flore des visites autour
de l'histoire de cet étang qui est très
riche qui est en étant artificiel pour
ceux qui ne sauraient et aussi en
spectacle donc voilà il y a vraiment des
façons différentes d'aborder le
patrimoine de manière conviviale drôle
plus sérieux et on peut combiner donc
voilà vous pouvez faire votre programme
à la carte et on peut rappeler que le
temps de 50 ans a été créé vous dit
artificielle parce qu'il a été créé pour
satisfaire les besoins du château de
Versailles
il est complètement créé de la main de
l'homme donc d'où son côté patrimoine
culturel aussi tout à fait parmi toutes
les animations qui aura donc à la base
de loisirs autour de l'étang de la base
de loisirs et la compagnie Talia pardon
théâtre qui va proposer un spectacle qui
s'appelle c'est dans l'eau on a
rencontré les comédiens et la metteur en
scène à Anne barlink est en répétition à
la verrière
cette année les Journées du patrimoine
sont dédiées à la nature et la culture
talia-théâtre a donc imaginé un
spectacle autour de l'eau un spectacle
présenté par des comédiens des musiciens
un circassiens la troupe de la
scarabande ils seront en représentation
à la base de loisirs de 50 ans en
Yvelines nous créons à partir d'images
que j'ai préparé et puis après on les
expérimente on essaie de voir si ça
tient la route
alors on va décliner l'eau l'eau des
loisirs l'eau historique
l'eau de la création
l'eau qui engloutit tout et l'eau qui
reprend son terrain et qui peut-être
nous fait disparaître si on fait pas
attention il y a une petite virgule au
parapluie de Cherbourg ici nous sommes
plutôt dans les parapluies de la
verrière ou de Trappes il y a des
petites virgules comme ça il y aura
Marie-Antoinette aussi par exemple
puisque elle elle a fait pas mal de
choses avec l'eau elle a vraiment voulu
la maîtriser et l'utiliser à fond
donc il y a des petites virgule des
petites images comme ça et nous avons un
mâchoire c'est le musée de la ville qui
a proposé la base de loisirs et nous
avons fait une visite ensemble pour voir
dans quel endroit nous pourrions faire
ce spectacle on a choisi un endroit un
petit peu
un petit peu entouré on va dire ça comme
ça il y aura aussi une petite expo de
photos et je pense que ça va être beau
convivial un peu drôle et puis on espère
qu'il pleuvra pas
ils ont des parapluies pour se protéger
et on est parapluies nous dans le public
on en a pas mais bon ce serait ce serait
logique c'est dans l'eau qu'on en prenne
un peu sur la tête mais on espère pas
quand même donc il faut rappeler c'est
une création et ça sera présenté donc
samedi donc on peut pas on s'est un
petit peu par avec Anne sur le contenu
du spectacle mais vous l'avez pas vu
l'heure encore
ça a l'air à la fois drôle à la fois
poétique à la fois un peu de réflexion
puisque c'est cyclique autour de l'eau
qui on est de l'eau et si on ne fait pas
attention à notre environnement elle
peut aussi nous engloutir donc voilà
c'est c'est tout mélanger je pense que
c'est accessible à tout le monde très
peu de texte beaucoup de poésie donc en
famille pas de problème voilà donc tu as
le théâtre ce sera samedi après-midi à
la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puis pour
rester dans le domaine de l'eau il y a
une rando patrimoine dimanche qui a lieu
tout à fait dernière place disponible
donc
à Guyancourt dimanche donc pareil
beaucoup de choses à dire autour de
l'eau du Moyen-Âge à l'époque
contemporaine un joli parcours entre
ville la nature vers les étangs de la
minière les sources de la Bièvre donc
très sympa aussi il reste donc à
beaucoup de place donc il faut aussi
précipiter et c'est important de
rappeler aussi que c'est gratuit tout
est gratuit tout est gratuit à
l'exception l'entrée on le rappelle de
la base de loisirs pour ceux qui
viennent en voiture tout est gratuit
alors les incontournables des patrimoine
à 50 ans en ligne c'est quand même le
musée de la ville et la commanderie des
Templiers on a comment les Templiers
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler un peu
l'historique de ce lieu oui c'est un
lieu très prestigieux fondé à la fin du
12e siècle la chapelle date du début du
13ème siècle qui est donc une
commanderie templière un lieu où les
moines de l'Ordre du Temple
pratiquer essentiellement l'agriculture
mais aussi un lieu qui était gardé donc
il y a un bâtiment des gardes un lieu
aussi fortifié et qui a traversé les
époques avec beaucoup d'histoires
beaucoup de changements beaucoup de
rebondissements vraiment des choses très
intéressantes à découvrir ou l'histoire
locale croise la grande Histoire et avec
des jolis vestiges et une chapelle qui
est rénovée depuis deux ans maintenant
et qui est vraiment un matériaux à
découvrir
il reste des places aussi pour le
concert dimanche à 17h qui a vraiment un
joli moment si vous avez jamais entendu
l'ensemble vocale de 50 ans en Yvelines
dans la chapelle de la Commanderie venez
parce que c'est un joli moment voilà et
ça couture particulière à l'ensemble
vocale dirigé par Valérie Josse est
toujours de très très bonne qualité ça
c'est pour la commanderie des Templiers
il reste des places donc ça c'est
chouette le musée de la ville alors nous
c'est de la ville on ouvre l'exposition
de la rentrée donc le 20 donc pour les
Journées du Patrimoine donc nouvelle
exposition qui est donc une exposition
sur un artiste Gérard Manoni qui a
travaillé comme beaucoup d'artistes à
l'extérieur à 50 ans en Yvelines sur la
rue urbain et qui est aussi un artiste
de renommée international qui a
travaillé la Biennale de Venise etc donc
voilà c'est contemporain dont le nom
n'est pas forcément aujourd'hui
extrêmement connu mais qui est vraiment
à découvrir avec de très belles oeuvres
une belle exposition des lumières
magnifiques et et voilà au musée de la
ville à partir de samedi
et on lui consacrera d'ailleurs un
reportage dans le prochain kiosque voilà
à autre moment fort je vais juste
préciser parce qu'on parle des choses
qui sont complexes week-end voilà il y a
plus de place pour visiter les coulisses
du théâtre de Saint-Quentin c'est bien
dommage et puis plus de place non plus
pour visiter l'observatoire de
l'Université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
mais on peut se rattraper pour la fête
de la science au mois d'octobre voilà
pour ceux qui veulent se rattraper
autrement fort à 50 ans en Yvelines la
petite église qu'on oublie qu'on voit
pas forcément et qui est fort jolie à
Manille les hameaux tout à fait avec un
ensemble de dalles funéraires protégé
donc vraiment un ensemble de qualité
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément et
effectivement il existe typique du
patrimoine francilien à découvrir ou à
redécouvrir pour certains voilà donc
c'est samedi et dimanche pour la
découverte de l'église Saint-Germain de
Paris à Manille aller à Meaux et
puisqu'on est à Manille à l'amour on
peut aussi faire la balade une balade de
4 km proposer autour de Port-Royal des
Champs
est assez mys
ça ça joue toujours
l'envoutement est toujours là quand les
visiteurs s'y présente qu'on connaisse
ou pas le lieu voilà une balade guidée
avec un pique-nique au milieu en plus
donc vraiment convivial n'hésitez pas
c'est toujours très sympa comme on
espère le beau temps pour dimanche donc
je rappelle que toutes ces animations
sont gratuites combien de personnes
l'année dernière donc elles ont des
journées du patrimoine alors on est
difficile à quantifier mais on est entre
1800 et 2000 personnes ces deux
dernières années à peu près avec à
chaque fois un jour de pas très beau
donc cette année on sent que on va
cartonner il va faire un temps
magnifique il faut rappeler que 50 ans
en Yvelines qui est une une vie nouvelle
a été la première vie nouvelle labelisée
ville d'art et d'histoire par le
ministère de la culture c'est une j'aime
bien une sacrée reconnaissance quand
même reconnaissance pour un patrimoine
contemporain c'est aussi une
reconnaissance pour un patrimoine
historique avec des grands sites comme
Port Royal les champs ou la Commanderie
qui ont tendance à être parfois gommés
par l'urbanisme contemporain donc ça
raccroche les wagons ce label et c'est
aussi une reconnaissance pour les
actions qui sont mises en place sur
l'agglomération pour faire découvrir
tout ça et pour finir de questions test
piège je sais pas mais est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on peut citer des architectes
connus qu'on a travaillé sur sur 50 ans
des artistes qui ont apporté leur pacte
oui effectivement il y a un certain
nombre d'architectes d'artistes de renom
donc on peut citer Ricardo beaufil
Dominique Perrot aussi l'auteur de la
Bibliothèque nationale que tout le monde
connaît mais on ne connaît pas tous les
immeubles lumière à 50 ans en Yvelines
on peut également citer comme artiste
des artistes comme Martin ou Dany
caravanes qui qu'on connaît pas toujours
parce que l'art contemporain on connaît
pas toujours mais c'est vraiment de
grands artistes qu'on travaille à
l'international et qui vraiment fait des
jolies choses sur notre territoire donc
il faut ouvrir l'oeil il y a plein de
choses à découvrir à 50 ans beaucoup de
choses merci beaucoup leur Valette pour
parler de ces 31e journée européenne du
patrimoine à 50 ans en Yvelines et je
vous propose maintenant on continue à
parler du patrimoine on va aller du côté
évidemment de Versailles le château qui
participe à ses journées après le succès
de l'ouverture de l'aile du midi c'était
en 2013 le château de Versailles
présente à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine les espaces et collections
des galeries historiques deux étages de
l'aile nord du château seront
exceptionnellement ouvert au public et
je vous propose écouter Frédéric
Lacaille
alors là vous allez découvrir au premier
étage des peintures surtout la espèce de
grande présentation du règne de Louis
XIV depuis son enfance jusqu'à sa mort
donc la grande figure de Versailles et
ici au second étage nous avons des
salles consacrées en fait à la
pratiquement au 19e siècle après
Napoléon c'est à dire depuis le retour
des Bourbons sur le trône en 1814 1815
avec les deux restaurations et jusqu'à
la Première Guerre mondiale donc un
siècle d'histoire de France la plupart
des visiteurs de Versailles ignorent
totalement en fait qu'il y a ce musée
historique qui a encore quelques sortes
cachée derrière la résidence royale
c'est comme la partie immergée en fait
d'un iceberg puisque les collections
historiques de Versailles sont un
ensemble absolument énorme que
Louis-Philippe avait installé dans tout
le château et petit à petit la résidence
royale a reconqui certains espaces les
appartements historiques mais il y a
toujours de très nombreuses salles
historiques que nous avons donc
l'occasion de montrer pour les Journées
du Patrimoine en attendant de pouvoir
les montrer plus plus souvent plus
facilement plus normalement en fait au
public d'ici on espère quelques années
et si vous n'avez pas tout retenu des
manifestations organisées pendant ces
journées du patrimoine je vous propose
un petit florilage alors et notez bien
prenez vos blogs au stylo vos tablettes
donc la commanderie des Templiers à
Élancourt vous ouvre ses portes samedi
et dimanche des visites guidées le
samedi après-midi des visites libres le
dimanche toute la journée avec des
animations exposition concert et compte
la visite du musée de la ville les
espaces d'exposition permanent pour
mieux comprendre le territoire 50-îois
elle sera aussi possible d'observer
l'exposition consacrée à Gérard Manoni
autre visite celle de l'Observatoire des
sciences de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin mais pas la peine de vous
précipiter je vous le rappelle puisque
c'est complet complet également complète
également la visite des coulisses du
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
allez autre autre programme l'étang de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à la croisée
des patrimoines le dernier maillon du
réseau des étangs supérieurs conçu au
17e siècle pour alimenter Versailles il
constitue aujourd'hui la base de loisirs
des spectacles avec taglia théâtre
samedi après-midi mais aussi des visites
historiques on reste dans le domaine de
la nature avec une découverte des fermes
de Magny-les-Hameaux elles sont au
nombre de quatre Gomberville bulloyées
les Granges de Port-Royal et chantent
Garnier à Saint-Lambert des bois c'est
un circuit pédestre et en bus qui est
proposé toujours au fil de l'eau une
rando promenade du lac de Villaroy au
douves de Châteauneuf en passant par la
source de la rivière Bièvre c'est
dimanche matin parcours de 6 km pour les
sportifs et puis dimanche matin
également on en a parlé avec leur
Valette la visite exceptionnelle du
château de La Verrière château construit
au 16ème siècle et on dit aussi que la
perspective du château aurait été créé
par Le Nôtre un magnilé à Meaux
ouverture exceptionnelle également de
l'église Saint-Germain de Paris dans le
vieux village de Manille abritant une
trentaine de pierres tombales liée à
l'ancienne abbaye de Port-Royal et
justement pour découvrir l'univers très
particulier de Port-Royal Deschamps à
Magny-les-Hameaux une balade champêtre
de 4 km bientôt programme prévoir un
petit pique-nique s'il fait beau bien
sûr allez plus étonnant peut-être cette
découverte du jeu au fabulisme cela va
se dérouler à les bibliothèques
universitaires de Guyancourt un jeu
conçu et réalisé par le Centre des
monuments nationaux par une équipe de
chercheurs de l'UVSQ et puis toujours à
Guyancourt retrouvez l'origine des arts
martiaux dans le hall du bâtiment Vauban
alors attention ces manifestations ont
lieu ce vendredi pour tout savoir sur
l'architecture le patrimoine
architectural de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin rendez-vous
dans le hall du bâtiment Vauban à
Guyancourt la construction des bâtiments
la naissance des laboratoires à la vie
des étudiants depuis 20 ans vous saurez
tout on reste dans l'agglomération avec
le fort de Saint-Cyr forme militaire
construit à Montigny après la guerre de
1870 et aménagé au début des années 80
pour recevoir les collections
photographiques de l'État s'appelait
toujours cette visite attrape une balade
à pied dans les quartiers historiques de
la ville pour évoquer une pierre et bien
la meulière voilà vous saurez tout sur
la meulière à Trappes un voisin le
Bretonneux une après-midi de concert en
plein air dans le parc de la croix du
bois avec les jeunes solistes d'Europe
et les solistes de Versailles donc de la
musique en plein air allez on va quitter
maintenant 50 ans en Yvelines on va
aller à Chevreuse animation et visite
bien entendu du très beau château de la
Madeleine il fut construit je le
rappelle à partir de la deuxième moitié
du 12e siècle
le Conseil général propose une visite du
Domaine de Madame Élisabeth alors c'est
un domaine qui était dessiné et créer
dans la seconde moitié du 18e siècle
pour le prince et la princesse de Rohan
Guéménée il a été racheté en 1793 par
Louis XVI et qui l'a offrait qu'il l'a
offert pardon à sa jeune sœur Madame
Elisabeth d'où le nom du domaine
toujours à Versailles et cela va
intéresser beaucoup de monde ça c'est
sûr il est possible de visiter le
conseil général et la préfecture ces
deux entités sont dansantes même
bâtiment bâtiment inauguré en 1867 il
présente notamment dans certaines pièces
un décor de plafond orné et de mobilier
qui témoignent de l'art de la fin du 19e
siècle et puis toujours à Versailles
évidemment l'incontournable château avec
l'ouverture exceptionnelle de l'aile
nord à découvrir les espaces et les
galets historiques à Versailles toujours
les artistes dans la rue un forum de
création artistique organisé par
l'association des élèves et anciens
élèves des Beaux-Arts de Versailles
on continue un petit peu plus loin à
découvrir aussi le Musée International
d'Art Naïf à Vic c'est une collection
constituée par un éditeur et amateur
d'art max fournit donc à découvrir AVIC
en plus le lieu est très sympa le
château de Breteuil lui aussi également
très sympa propose plusieurs animations
le dimanche 21 parmi celles-ci un bal
sur le thème Autant en emporte le vent
donc choisissez vos plus belles robes
mesdames également des contes et des
promenades dans les jardins et puis pour
finir direction Coignières avec l'église
Saint-Germain l'Auxerrois une ouverture
exceptionnelle une attention
particulière sur le vitrail de la
Nativité et les statues restaurées il y
a 10 ans voilà ça vous fait quand même
un large programme de découverte de quoi
faire on poursuit le kiosque avec la
chronique de Nicolas Gervais
elle nous fait découvrir cette semaine
le festival de Food rock Amani à léamo
qui aura lieu dès les 10 et 11 octobre
prochain
Lofofora no one is innocentes les villes
deadlines c'est bien d'autres pour ça va
piquer foudre que cette année c'est
toujours à Manille c'est les 10 et 11
octobre et c'est Guillaume Le tocard le
vice-président de l'assaut le VIP comme
on dit dans Sound Of Anarchy qui nous en
parle quand même quoi
c'est un festival qui tournait
essentiellement autour du rock enfin on
essaye de couvrir un maximum de styles
mais c'est centré autour de tout ce qui
a une guitare électrique un festival
convivial qui dure 2 jours et qui est
situé à Magny-les-Hameaux à l'estaminet
c'est la quatrième édition cette année
on monte en popularité en notoriété
cette année on a de belles nouveautés on
a des très bons groupes Fofora no one is
innocent
le vendredi on a Sylvie Larsson qui sera
en tête d'affiche avec
Noan is innocent donc c'est une des
seules dates qui vont faire sur toute
l'année 2014 donc ils ont choisi de
faire le Food rock et puis un groupe du
coin qui est Wiz gasoline donc qu'on a
mis en avant parce que on reçoit
énormément de propositions de toute la
France et on sélectionne généralement
des groupes de la région
le samedi on aura en tête d'affiche
Lofofora qui sont un album en septembre
donc on est la première date pour pour
le retourner ce qui est ce qui est
excellent pour eux et pour nous on aura
aussi living Deadlight qui a un groupe
des US donc une exclusivité aussi
puisque l'année dernière on avait Buire
Dolls et puis cette année on a lu des
blagues qui est un peu dans le site des
Guns N' Roses
on aura Loding data donc un groupe de
stoneer parisien qui est en train de
monter en puissance on adore jusqu'à un
groupe qui a une vingtaine d'années qui
est un métal atmosphérique de quelque
chose très très particulier mais mais
dont les fans aiment beaucoup et puis on
aura fait down qui a un groupe aussi de
du coin de Guyancourt là qui est dans le
style très métallique et très et très
assez violent mais qui plaît beaucoup
aussi dans le coin
les nouveautés c'est living Deadlight
c'est vraiment le groupe américain qui
n'a jamais joué en France donc ils ont
ils vont tourner un clip de quelques
jours avant sur Paris il viendront jouer
chez nous et puis ils vont commencer
toute une tourne européenne donc ça
c'est la grosse nouveauté du coup il
joueront en acoustique ça c'est un peu
une exclue là que je vous donne mais ils
vont jouer en acoustique le vendredi
donc les gens qui viendront le vendredi
pourront les voir sur quelques morceaux
on acoustique dans le bar
15 euros l'entrée 25 sur les deux jours
sans intérieur de son mois d'octobre
donc on peut rappeler les dates c'est le
10 et 11 octobre vendredi samedi on est
tout à fait à l'abri des intempéries et
la particularité c'est qu'on est très
proche des artistes c'est-à-dire que on
a une salle on a un bar et les tout ça
ça se mélange les groupes ils sont dans
le bar pendant que pendant qu'il ne joue
pas etc donc ça crée une communauté et
le finalement le rock c'est ça si on vit
tombé tous l'événement on est tous des
passionnés
et voilà pour le rock et maintenant on
retrouve Catherine en plateau et moi je
vous dis à la semaine prochaine
et du cinéma avec ce soir le coup de
coeur d'un professionnel du septième art
Bertrand Pinier du cinéma Les Yeux
d'Elsa de Saint-Cyr-l'École le coup de
cœur de la semaine au cinéma Les Yeux
d'Elsa à Saint-Cyr-l'École c'est le
compte de la princesse Kaguya le dernier
né de la des studios Ghibli après le
vent se lève dernier film annoncé de
Hayao Miyazaki voici le dernier film
annoncé de Isa otakaata son comparse de
toujours c'est donc l'histoire d'une
princesse qui n'est dans un bambou c'est
un conte qui date du 9e siècle au Japon
que tous les Japonais connaissent que
nous connaissons moins mais que Isa
Otaka reprend pour en faire une sorte de
compte d'aide à la nature au lien entre
l'homme et la nature c'est un film qui
est accessible d'être très petit des 6-7
ans et c'est un film avec un univers
graphique absolument foisonnant avec une
musique absolument bouleversante et une
histoire qui plaira à tout le monde des
plus petits au plus âgés
je vous invite à venir le voir au cinéma
Les Yeux d'Elsa donc dès cette semaine
et puis encore pour une semaine puisque
c'est un film qu'on a décidé de soutenir
et de garder un peu longtemps
allez kiosque c'est terminé bonne soirée
à vous et excellente journée du
patrimoine à bientôt